hi Cora if you tell me this is a  practical joke well it kills me to say  it but I would be really impressed  impressing you K is the easiest thing  I'll do all day  hi Cora what have you got someone or  something has sabotaged the skyline  defense systems every sensor beyond the  wall was gone dark  [Applause]  battle stations  everyone with me now  your journey ends this enemy has taken  our home and now they threaten our very  existence  but if we attack together we can take  back our home or we die trying  [Music]  all right guardian  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  am i right am i right or am i right  [Music]  [Music]  pre-order and get beta early access